bring it sister they're back the first  look at the Real Housewives of Orange  County Season eleven dropped Monday and  it teased plenty of drama gloves are off  let's go baby talk your baby baby baby  baby a sassy new cast mate Kelly Meza  Dodd I think the best way to get over  somebody is to get under somebody else  and Vicki Gunvalson and Tamra judges  scary sand dune accident et learned in  April that the cast mates were pretty  shaken up by the crash while filming in  Glamis California and from the looks of  this trailer they had every right to be  we can't wait to see more of the drama  that this season has in store The Real  Housewives of Orange County premieres on  Bravo Monday June 20th